hi everybody welcome back to another
episode of
big mood uh i am your host today you got
gina
you got nikki tiff and jess and today's
episode is just
just a ketchup we want to catch up on
everyone's life catch up to all this
energy that a mustard
m m reference yeah it's like a pun
ketchup mustard oh okay
[Laughter]
but we're going to catch up because you
know life has been crazy it's been a few
months since we've done a catch-up
episode i feel like a lot of things have
happened
particularly in gina's life very
publicly that we haven't spoken about in
this show no we haven't yet
what's up we always do like topics
i didn't oh you didn't david covered it
on his own
i like david covered my life david stole
all of you right now
no but we actually have the person that
it happened too
like david's views why did you do this
without me he had to ed i'm like
all right that's cool whatever i am
celebrity gossip
right it's funny yeah life has been yeah
how does it feel to have people talking
about you now
yeah so their show you get to be the
team right
oh my god it like this is crazy the
first time i decided to go public with
whoever i'm dating
it turned out to be like the worst and
it has and now the whole internet knows
that i had chlamydia yeah
that's like all right it's okay girl i
had chlamydia for free in college too
wow for free you guys are nasty didn't
even get whatever you didn't even get a
boyfriend
yeah put a stigma on you oh my god
uh yeah it's been [ __ ] crazy man
because you guys know me like 11 years
in this business i never go public
with a relationship ever like i'll tell
stories and whatever i never say names
and i always change the date on things
yeah on your instagram stories it's
always for close friends
yeah you do story your man or if i would
be careful with that
what if you forget to hit that button oh
yeah all right thank god i haven't
but she's been wild man okay so fill
everyone in for people that don't know
if you don't know you should follow gina
on tick tock because
yeah that's where the long story there's
like 10.
10 stories it's about 10 parts yeah 10
60 second parts
um you were dating this guy you finally
thought like ah
cute relationship time yeah so i was
dating this guy that i met on tik tok
um very out of character for me because
i never dating one younger than me
but i figured like he seemed to be very
so much younger than you
i'm 31 he was 25. so i'm like six years
six years yeah
that's a bit cool under 26 no yeah
which is usually my deal too under 30 is
not really my thing
and that's no offense to all of you
under 26. it's just you're going to be a
different person after 26.
you will you're just getting to know
yourself yeah
so i mean we dated for two months we've
known each other for like six or seven
months but we dated for two months
because of like
just he just seemed very mature and he
like convinced me and you know like
oh yeah you know i was homeless at one
point and i was in the military and all
that
um and the type of person i am is i'm
very
i like to give people a benefit of doubt
you know as
as kind of a [ __ ] as i am i'm you
know i try to see the good in people
yeah so we dated for two months
especially when they have abs yeah yeah
especially when they have that [ __ ]
like knife look to you like you like
people that have that like
sharp [ __ ] handsome face jawline yeah
yeah
yeah so we did it for two months it was
brief um
but we had like the whole like
commitment talk like you know he's
committed to me he doesn't want to talk
to anyone
long story short he uh dumped me out of
nowhere
saying that i had trust issues because i
questioned him about something because
for some reason i couldn't trust him
the whole entire relationship
something's good yeah yeah it's never
wrong
and i figured um it was just like
maybe i'm overthinking things you know
and
uh dumped me saying i trust issues and
for two weeks
i was like very confused like we never
argued we never had problems or anything
so it was very out of the blue
and complete flag yeah completely just
like refused to
reply like i sent one text message after
we split
and he didn't reply i'm like that's all
right you know random
very random you got too close to the
fire
yeah the truth exactly so uh
for two weeks i was like questioning
myself like i very much doubted myself
yeah yeah yeah because you had just been
covering that in therapy yeah
yeah and two weeks later
i me and our group of tik-tok buddies
we're all on a group chat
him included and we discussed like do
you want to go are we all going to this
this drive-in theater event it's an
asian-american
drive-in theater event hosted by an
asian-american production
app and whatever of our friends david
choi
and abe and all them and i'm like yeah
let's let's go originally
it was me him and our other two friends
that plan to go but then the whole tick
tock crew decided to go
this was planned a month before but now
that we're split it's like all right
whatever
uh he saw that i was going in the chat
and i figured he didn't reply so i
figured he's not going to go because he
doesn't want
anything awkward but then on the way
there i found out through our friends
that he was going to be there
i was like oh okay cool fine and then
it's by some miracle of god i have no
idea how this happened it was karma it
was a universe or something
they it was a first come first served
park where they
could drive in they tell you where to
drive right my car
throughout the whole theater gets parked
right behind his and i was like
oh [ __ ] this is gonna be a little bit
awkward but it's fine like my car our
friend's car
later on i found out david was right
next to us too um but his car was right
in front of ours and i was like oh [ __ ]
you know i'm not gonna make it weird if
he wants coming out with our friends of
course i'm not gonna make it weird
but then i saw like a second shadow in
the passenger seat i was like what the
[ __ ]
and then our friend's like no he
wouldn't do that you know that's [ __ ]
up and so they all went over to say hi
to him
it was another girl and uh he stepped
out of his car real quick and he's like
oh but
you know don't say anything about what i
do for a living she doesn't know
and then everyone came the group came
back to me they're like that's really
[ __ ] up that
he brought a girl knowing that you would
come when he was only split two weeks
before
and then one a couple of guys didn't
know that we dated
and the whole group was just kind of
questioning like where'd he meet this
girl she doesn't know what he does
yeah that's weird you know for someone
with 2.7 million on tick tock
how does she weird to date someone
that's not your fan
so a couple of guys i didn't know we
were dating mentioned
or they they said oh yeah he briefly
mentioned earlier that he met her on
hinge
a dating app and that's when everything
came spilling out because
our whole group is like what the [ __ ]
like he's told us since day one i don't
believe in dating apps they make men
weak
i think it's cheap dating i don't
everyone should get off of it hypocrite
hypocrite projection huge projection and
then so we all start talking like
one person is like yeah you know what i
did notice that he was a hypocrite about
this
another one's like yeah i didn't notice
that he did this and it all started
coming out
slowly right and then um i remember that
a family member of one of his exes tried
to comment on my videos once
um saying like why are you talking to
this guy why are you working with him
he's a
piece of [ __ ] and he cheated on my
cousin i thought it was just a hater
i remember texting it to him too saying
like oh look at this he's like
oh geez never heard that one before
that's crazy so
i was like i remembered that so i went
back on our text message
find that photo of that uh user messaged
that user
and she put me in touch with the
ex-girlfriend so i hit up the
ex-girlfriend like hey
something doesn't seem right i know this
is really [ __ ] weird
can we talk about this and she's like oh
yeah dude let's let's talk about it
i'm like yeah you know i just um saw him
with a girl that he met on a dating app
he said he doesn't believe in dating
apps
and she's like uh really because he met
me on a dating app and then he met the
girl he chewed on me with on a dating
app
everything came out everything came out
literally everything
it's like lie after live live after july
like
and then i got in touch with another
girl that he
gave chlamydia to and she informed him
in january she called him up she's like
hey
i have chlamydia i got it from you i
haven't slept with anyone else before
you so it's definitely from you
you know she's been like celibate before
that and
he was like okay i'll get it checked
well he told her in january
i was with him in january we had already
started dating
and he never told me why wouldn't he try
to get clean too
he claims he claims it's oh because i
figured i didn't have any symptoms so i
wouldn't have it
oh my god like this is like weapons
grade stupidity
by the way there's a full google doc
right so twitter if you want to check it
out
so with all the overlaps of lies
so originally that google doc was just
me and his two ex-girlfriends that he
cheated on
and all the lies and everything right
well after i posted the videos on tik
tok everything went viral
like within a few hours and then i
thought i was done for the night i did
my last video
but then i started getting message after
message after message from all these
women that live in l.a
hey i met him too on i matched with him
and he did this and he did that and he
did that like
these terrible stories i was about to
just go to bed but then i got all these
messages i was like
what the [ __ ] like this is you think you
know somebody yeah
like it was insane how like disgusting
does that make you feel to know that
there's just like
hundreds of girls in la that oh classic
narcissist it's just insane like
i was just like i'm not the person to
hear this story because i'm already
[ __ ] angry at the stage
at the state of men in the state of
dating and i'm like i'm just reading all
this [ __ ] like
yeah i knew it i feel like an old
married woman
so you know all those messages came out
it and it really really hit me that so
the reason why i went public in the
first place is not because he cheated on
me not because i don't give a [ __ ] about
that you know or he lied or he gave me
an std it's fine i don't care
but when i found out that he knew and
knowingly gave me the std
burn and found out that he was sleeping
with other people also
knowing that he had it this became like
a public health issue
and this is when i realized like i can't
just let this happen
because if you guys don't know
chlamydia if you leave it for too long
it can render a woman
um infertile yeah and that's
really devastating so i decided [ __ ] now
i have to go public like
this i felt like it was like a
responsibility at this point because so
many women came out
and i realized he was doing this to so
many women he was continuing to do it
um so
went public all these messages came out
i was like all right so i started
screenshotting all these messages
of course i asked them for consent first
changed all their names put them in the
google drive
the google drive became like about 100
or a little bit over a hundred slides
oh my god like 20 something women
came out um me
one two and three other women confirmed
with chlamydia from him
he also like keep trophies from you guys
too like jewelry
jewelry like he from his ex-girlfriends
he would wear it that's a classic sign
too
yeah the trophies so i demanded i
demanded to get mine back
um have you yeah oh nice yeah he was so
much of a coward he gave it to our
mutual friend to give it to us
but like all these things started coming
out like even lying about
what he did in the military where he
used to work
um just everything it was crazy like our
group of friends
was heartbroken too because one of them
was very close to him and our group of
friends was just like who the [ __ ] is
this guy like yeah
it makes you question your own choices
and picking people too right right like
well no not really like i don't blame
like i can't
really super blame myself or our friends
because we all got fooled
yeah you know cause that's where yeah
it's definitely not your fault but i can
see
how like the mentality can go that that
way and spiraling
you feel uneasy for at least a time
being yes
holy [ __ ] they're really charismatic
though
like that's how they get where they are
and how they
stay narcissistic yeah so yeah i did at
one point i was kind of mad at myself
like how the [ __ ] did i let this guy in
when i'm very closed off
yeah you know and i was talking to our
group of friends who like some of them
are very seasoned in
the entertainment business and they're
we were all really upset like we've
spent vacations with you like
trips and all this like we let you into
our home who the [ __ ] are you
yeah um they get off on finding your
weak spots and like excuse me yeah i
think
they they go for like the strongest the
smartest so
you know like because it's more of a
game for them it is exceeds their ego
even more when they exit the person
that's at the top
they can find someone that's so strong
they can find their weak spots yeah
and then when we met i was at a very
vulnerable point like i
went through like two traumas and some
crazy [ __ ] and he knew that
so i was extremely vulnerable and so
perfect yeah um but long story short
all that happened he got cancelled hard
he released like a written notes
app [ __ ] apology yeah i read that
that was the apology was so
bad it was like a pity a pity plea
it was like but it was okay i'm sorry
but look at all the stuff that happened
to me
yeah like it was also like it didn't
look genuine at all
like and then you did the video one
right where he like where he was like
i'm just like screen that's the worst
apology i've ever seen
it made it so much worse ever yeah he
didn't address anything that he did
he was a lot of native american people
for some reason that was weird that was
weird
we're like what the [ __ ] was that um
didn't address anything
but he pretty much got cancelled um when
this all
burned and like all over one of our
close friends the one mutual close
friend that we have
that considered him a brother was like
the whole time's like you need to
apologize to gina in person you have to
do it you have to do it but he was like
no my conscience is clear i did nothing
wrong
just pathological liar and then so he
finally himself he's like he's like to
himself
so much like he believes his own lives
yeah
so he finally texted
saying hey i want to apologize like two
weeks after this all
came crashing down on him and or a week
and a half or two
i'm like all right sure he's like
however well you want him like do it in
person at my house
like i just want to see what happens
like i want to see what he you know your
face um a day
before he was supposed to come over
another mutual friend of ours
uh well she was a friend of his but she
decided to reach out to me
she was like hi um i feel like i need to
tell you this i just got off the phone
with him
and the things he said was just i feel
like you need to know because i've lost
all respect for him i was like okay
she's like he considered me his little
sister but the things he said i just
can't
he said um oh you know gina is just this
crazy ex she's making up lies she's just
crazy you know those crazy girls oh my
gosh
of course i've never been a crazy so
much of my ex oh my god i heard all that
same [ __ ] too my
all my exes are crazy and they all like
make up the [ __ ] huge red flags and then
what do they have in common and all the
trophies and all
and then he says i don't know why she's
overreacting about the chlamydia she's
being so dramatic oh my god
and i was like okay and this was a day
of yours
yeah a day before he was supposed to
come over to apologize right after you
text me i want to go
[ __ ] you want to see me over react yeah
right you want to see crazy you haven't
seen crazy
like this is just i'm not like you
haven't seen me go crazy you know
so he comes over to apologize um but you
know desperate men could be dangerous
so just to be safe i had two of my
buddies come over one of them is a
special forces uh
uh army veteran um
and he he's met this guy before i don't
give a [ __ ] his name's richoy [ __ ] you
um anyways uh retro uh
rachel and his real name is samuel choi
and
um so he's met my special forces buddy
before and just like
was gushing all over him because he's
that's everything he's ever wanted to be
you know he wanted to be that military
veteran whatever so
when he came over all of us were armed
but hidden of course we can't brandish
that's not
okay so when he came over he rang my
doorbell my friend came out he's like
back up back up like he patted him down
empty his pockets into a tupperware you
have a doorbell cam right
i do i watched this thing i recorded it
i got to see this
absolutely we need some like we need to
like put
some of that image into this video right
now
[Laughter]
so he came in um i was sitting here
he was sitting facing me my friends were
sitting behind him facing him
just in case he tries to do anything i
wasn't really scared
because i realized how much of a little
[ __ ] he was he's actually super weak
yeah he's actually really weak even
though he always boasted about like i'm
a man i'm
a manly whatever but how he handled this
whole situation how he couldn't
i realized like he's you were you're
kind of a very weak small man
yeah that's how they are yeah so their
power from
sucking off of strong people yeah
exactly what weak people do
yeah so i recorded the whole entire
apology
and for legal purposes i asked him
questions
for him to have to admit to things that
he could deny like
do you know you know that girl that told
you initially that you had chlamydia
he's like yes i'm like what and he said
january i'm like what's her name he said
her name like good
so that's on camera you know and then i
was like
so i heard you said that i was
overreacting about the chlamydia
yesterday
and you're saying that i was a crazy
[ __ ] and then he's like
what i'm like yeah your friend told me
so i don't think you're [ __ ] sorry at
all
and then he was like okay i'm sorry i
didn't mean that i'll take it back like
oh my god
but the best part was because he's
always said that i'm a man i'm bomb
integrity loyal like manly man i asked
him about his military service
and then my friend who um was a staff
sergeant at one point
i think yeah i don't remember um
chewed him out like full-on chewed him
out
i got scared because i've never seen him
like this like who the [ __ ] are you to
say that you were spec ops
like my brothers have died in that
uniform you don't get to [ __ ] say
that
you never disrespect my uniform yeah
that stolen thing is like a big
no no yeah so like i said my friends
were sitting behind him and then he's
like
were you in the military he's like yes
and he goes
you [ __ ] look at me when you answer
me he like went all drills
yeah and i was like oh [ __ ] like i've
never i love how he was petting your cat
while he was doing this yeah
that was my favorite part the the drill
sergeant
was a little petty cat it was amazing um
well uh you know hopefully
you shaved your life did you shave your
legs during this
confrontation before he's shaving his
legs now
crushing such a
[Applause]
yes billy thanks to our sponsor billy
so you know how our women's razors they
always have that stupid pink tax for
some reason they want to charge us
more just because we're women to buy a
razor
it's ridiculous so personally and i know
a lot of women do this i have used
and bought men's razors because they
tend to
in my opinion they work better they end
up not giving you that pink tack so i
pay
less for good razors good quality razors
but not anymore buddy you know why
because now i got billy so billy is the
best razor out there for those days when
you want that extra smooth
shave with no pink tacks no visit to the
drugstore and no
breaking the bank you can go to
mybilly.com to get their starter kit for
just
nine dollars it's so affordable and
includes
their award-winning razor two refill
blades
and a cult favorite magnetic holder go
to mybilly.com to meet the razor that
made
everyone start talking about razors and
to express
a little love for our show go to
mybilly.com
mood it's a small way you can support us
while getting the best razor you
will ever own it's just nine dollars to
get your starter kit plus
free shipping always go to mybilly.com
mood spelled my b i l
l i e dot com slash mood
it's so cute they have a little holder
yeah it's like a magnetic holder yeah
the whole packaging is adorable it's
super adorable i also want to give a
shout out to
noom it's not just about weight loss
like the way that you think about it
traditionally it's about how to build
healthy habits and just become a
healthier person in general it's based
in science
it's built by psychologists and noom
doesn't give you the rules but instead
teaches you
how to change your mindset so that you
can accomplish your personal health
goals
stick with them long term and get
healthy for good
i felt like i had a snacking habit
only when i had anxiety or stress and i
didn't
realize that the two were connected
until i went through the program and i
went through the app and
it kind of like asks you like you know
what to just be
more aware like what times do you grab
these these
snacks or you know what times do you do
these bad habits and to be more aware of
it you you know
journal do different things and then uh
different exercises that can help you so
it's only 10 minutes a day and the tone
of the program works with your lifestyle
you don't have to commit to a rigorous
plan
it's based in psychology and it uses a
cognitive behavioral approach which
means you're not just improving your
health
you're gaining the knowledge and habits
you need to stay healthy and that's the
important part cause you you have crash
diets and then you like you lose weight
but then
you get it right back because your
mindset didn't change you just like
did a crazy thing band-aid this is like
yeah this is like an ongoing
lifestyle change and everyone's busy
that's why noob doesn't demand much of
your time it's just 10 minutes a day
there's a science to getting healthier
it's called noom sign up for your trial
today at noom
noom.com big mood learn how to get
healthy with noom sign up for your trial
today at
noomnoom.com big mood
ready to learn how to live healthier
sign up for noom today at
noom.com big mood
but i don't want to take up you know all
the time about the story if you guys
want to know about definitely the
juiciest thing yeah
haven't i got nothing going on i learned
all about having an inflatable hot tub
but you know i'll get to that
stuff jess has stuff going on we'll talk
about that
what if you guys want to know the whole
story go to my tick tock yeah yeah yeah
it's
it's really a very long and insane
roller coaster
of the story so that
documentary style yeah got the netflix
series if you want to scare
yourself from dating in the in la and in
the current period in time
uh yeah that story will definitely do it
for you you know yep predator on the
loose
let's say you get to learn from this
experience though and then now you know
the red flags
yeah yeah yeah i've i've learned
i've learned a lot but i've also learned
that when i'm angry i'm at my best
never have i seen gina prep a google doc
before i know i know
you did more work for this than you've
done for our entire show for
like a year i have to be angry yeah you
know i'm just like chronologically
ordered yeah i would piss you off every
time we have a shoot day
my lawyer buddies hit me up like dude
you could have been a great prosecutor
i was like thank you you could have been
a pretty good lawyer but jess what about
you
yeah you just got back from texas texas
what's going on there
texas big announcement all right i don't
even know if i've told you guys
everything that i've had planned or i've
been doing i have no idea what's going
on
um so i'll get okay i'm gonna just say
what's happening and then we'll start
from the beginning of my
like mental mental journey yes i'm just
gonna say first though if just leaves us
in any way whatsoever at any capacity
i'm offing myself
no that's not true gina first of all you
can't say that and second of all
you said that you would hang out at
every single hangout or else she would
leave
and then you ditched the first hang out
so she's like very first [ __ ] hang
out
very much very first okay do you know
why
because of all the read [ __ ] i was
getting an std test
all right well it wasn't that day no you
were at least no you were like my
brother you thought
oh that's my brother okay sorry my
brother was in town sorry no but i loved
her
yeah no but the day before you thought
that that's when we were hanging out but
it was the next day so that the day
before you were already going on oh yeah
try it with us we'll put together a
google doc
exactly you ain't you pissed us off do
you overlapping lies
but i thought it was a saturday so i
woke up early and i was ready i was
ready to go
anyway it's your fault it's your fault
and i asked you guys one time they're
like it's tomorrow [ __ ] i was like [ __ ]
my brother's here tomorrow so i was
ready on saturday i was up and
no you were trying to you were trying to
cancel on saturday you were we have this
yeah we have the shots [ __ ] yeah girl
you know i feel bad for jesus as far as
this situation
is i want to have the option i want to
have the option
i won't have the option of canceling on
just you know i don't want to not
have that option anymore that okay sorry
so
all of that to say i have come to the
conclusion that i
this is very crazy but i am going to go
ahead and move back to texas even though
a few short months ago i was like
magic [ __ ] all you people leave i think
it was like september the last time we
we talked about i think castle was here
and
because i was talking about vegas and
you were like [ __ ]
yeah so that i guess started
the brain processing of me thinking
about it even though at first it was
like a hell yeah
but what would that look like no that's
too crazy what would it look like yeah
yeah so
yeah so basically i i've traded in my
bmw
big move big move and um i'm gonna
break my lease and move probably at the
end of may
holy [ __ ] that fast yeah so fast
initially i was gonna wait until yeah
either after my birthday or like
november she keeps moving it up so like
police was
at november right october yeah
thirty-one
dollars
making the decision now okay make your
decision not to leave at the end of june
so you can have your birthday party and
it won't be retrograde and things could
go smoothly for you
but i thought it doesn't matter what you
do in mercury retrograde if you're
signing a new lease
i'm not going to sign the new lease i'm
just going to stay at my house for like
a month if you're traveling
what happens if something happens in the
world okay look i can't live my life
around [ __ ] mercury yes you can
um but yeah so yeah so yesterday i
traded in my bmw
my baby my i love you you'll get her
back
she she has my heart with her somewhere
she's in los angeles she knows
and okay so this is like the lamest [ __ ]
i'm ever gonna say
but it was my choice to turn in the car
right because i started making all these
financial plans and doing all these
[ __ ] calculations and i was like oh
i'm gonna [ __ ] have
this big ass [ __ ] stack of cash if i
make a couple of little
um adjustments to my spending but when
it came time to turn in the
bmw i started getting emotional because
i was like this is my first
luxury like major luxury purchase it it
symbolized something for me that i
hadn't
ever realized was so big which was just
the achievement of like
getting something on my own um
feeling like for once that i wasn't just
a piece of trash i guess like and i
don't know like i mean getting a nice
car doesn't mean you're not a piece of
trash or doesn't mean that you are or
whatever but just a symbol
of like i i got like someone handed me
the keys to a 77
000 car and let me drive it someone let
me take that car home you know so that
meant something to me like it
i guess it was just a self-actualization
of like oh wow i can do
bigger things than where i mean i was in
a shelter at one point with my mom as a
kid so like for me that was a big deal
yeah so i was very emotionally attached
to that car but
um so like over december when it was
getting real [ __ ] quiet because of
the pandemic was just
real bad lockdown i spent a lot of time
thinking like about
my family life and like things i just
started realizing oh you know i'm
actually
i'm not i'm like 1200 miles away from my
family and then like
not being able to see you guys very much
either too started making me think of
like what's
what's really important in life and i'm
like well our friendships are
are kind of like on a once or twice a
month basis anyway
and um most of my life i i'm alone
in la so even though we're super tight i
am still spending a lot of time alone
even without the pandemic i feel like
we're only going to hang out like two or
three times a month everyone's just so
busy like you have your own lives
and also you guys are trying to be moms
and gina is over here [ __ ] getting
all these crazy
streaming contracts and [ __ ] and i'm
just like i'm just literally by myself a
lot so then i started thinking oh um
you know maybe maybe i'll move back like
at some point you know and then it just
it started escalating more and more of
like okay well maybe i'll go ahead and
move back at the end of this year
i would like to be closer to my dad
actually you know he doesn't have a
whole lot of years left
so even if i moved back to texas for
like a year or two at least i got
another year or two closer to him and
then i could go somewhere else later
blah blah blah so just all of this like
stuff like going through my head i'm
like oh i should buy a house
i should start building more assets
absolutely right now in l.a what i'm
doing is just [ __ ] taking cash that
we're making and lighting it on fire
yeah like i'm spending a [ __ ] a ton of
money on my rent spending a [ __ ] time
money in my car
all this stuff and i'm like you know
what
it's been fun and i feel like i i chose
to
like get that expensive apartment and i
chose to get that expensive car because
to me it felt like i
needed that kind of liberation you had
your financial hope
yeah i was like i was being financially
[ __ ] yeah
even though i haven't liked that even
though i have an mba
and like i understand like finding yeah
and stuff like that but i just wanted to
be a [ __ ]
me be impulsive for once in my life hot
girl financial summer
it was it was a hot girl financial stuff
so then
but then after you know a few months i
was like the the newness of it were off
and i was like wait my
i could i do still like material things
let me tell you yeah
but i was realizing i could take that
money now
invest it now and have even more later
so like why
kind of blow so much of it now whereas
you know the saying is time in the
market
like when it comes to compounding yeah
time is not on your side if you do not
start early so
and i didn't start early but you're
still you're still
on the cusp like 30s is still okay like
you're still going to be fine
40s you're gonna have to work your
[ __ ] ass off and 50s you're really
gonna have to have some miracles being
pulled
so like i think that is the greatest
decision you can make and also
i agree with you having that impulsive
year because you'll always like
have that yearning in you if you didn't
get it out of your system and
the fact is like now you know you can do
that i think that's the whole point is
like when you grow up poor
you're like told no all the time like i
can't have that i can't have that
and then when you finally can do it
you're like oh [ __ ]
is it the best decision maybe not but at
least you could take
not being that reckless because like you
know there's there's these little
like um i don't know what you call it
like rules of finance right they're like
don't get a car that's more than 10
of your monthly income yeah my car
wasn't more than 10 of my monthly income
even that bmw
being as expensive as it was i still
didn't surpass that threshold they're
like your rent shouldn't be more than
three or four times your income or
whatever or it should be a third
third or third or a fourth of your
income i'm like i mean i'm meeting all
these thresholds
right but it's still a lot of
dollars that yeah that should be going
somewhere else
so i'm just like you know what if you
could have an
asset under your belt yeah that would be
way better over time
at least that's that's a thing that's
working for like it's making you money
while you don't have to work
yeah then your time and money aren't
directly correlated where like
you're only making the amount of money
that you're putting time into right
so yeah i just really decided like and i
started looking at my finances and i
made a ton of [ __ ] spreadsheets
because you know i'm a great big [ __ ]
nerd and i'm making spreadsheets
two different things that's way too many
different priorities mine is a [ __ ]
verb now like you better
[ __ ] up i'm gonna google drive your
asking exactly what happens
so i google drive to my finances
so i basically i traded in my bmw so i
had a 2020
x4 m competition series bmw which i
[ __ ]
you'll get you'll you know i traded it
in i got a
chevy blazer the rs model which is a
higher
level i still i couldn't i had to still
be a little bougie okay
okay i was talking to nikki i was like i
can't like go that far down
and with my insurance will go down
because i'm no longer driving a [ __ ]
almost 80 000
car um i'll be saving 500 a month on
car [ __ ] and then moving to austin i'll
be saving twenty five hundred dollars a
month on rent so that's three grand
in my pocket [ __ ] yeah everything that
makes me wanna i'm not doing anything
new
or more or different i'm just not
spending yeah and i'm
saving three grand that's gonna add up
fast well you're gonna live in another
state but yeah i know but
like with no taxes with no state taxes
dude your money goes there's no no
gas is cheaper it's like for the gas
because i had to get premium gas in my
bmw and we're in la so it was like 450 a
gallon
it's like half that in texas and also
i prob my car this car doesn't eat up as
much gas as that one so
there's just all kinds of little things
where i'm like i'm going to be saving so
much money in so many different
directions
and i just got really inspired who's
that youtuber you're talking about green
graham
stefan yeah i was watching more of his
videos and
you should also watch meet kevin holy
[ __ ] meet kevin yeah meet kevin's
amazing
is he plug plug i love me kevin he's a
youtuber that he's a youtuber well him
and grab stefan actually have a
podcast together with another person or
two other people but i only watched them
um but grant they're both in real estate
and but uh meet kevin
is really good at breaking down the
numbers and like
you can start with ten thousand and this
is how you make a hundred grand in a
year or whatever like he's
really good at that and i just like the
way his brain works and the way that
he's a good teacher
and like with with numbers and like
breaking down specifics
so i mean like logically i feel like
none of that stuff is really new for me
but i
but listening to them i think it was
more motivating on a psychological level
because it's like
i've gone through a master's program in
business and finance and blah blah blah
like i know all the stuff i've been an
accountant i understand
how things work but i never personalized
it i never thought like oh that
that matters to me it's just like this
is what you should do and i can list
what you're supposed to do but i never
internalized
those behaviors so i don't have the type
of assets that i
would like to have had like when i was
back in texas and i was working in
accounting i had a 401k i had a decent
income and all that but when i left and
came out here
to la to work with joe like my income
severely dropped like he just
yeah i worked for his company right jk
but i was just making enough just to
cover
like my car payment and my phone bill
and stuff like i wasn't making more
money but jess i thought you moved here
and you're a gold digger oh yeah
i didn't make more money when i first
moved here because he was just like
letting me live there
for free and he would give me just
enough money to like cover my
minimum expenses and i was doing stuff
for him and his company and stuff so
and that was fine that was our agreement
that was totally great now we're not
together he's paying me a market wage so
thanks boo but um so
so yeah so i'll have that still as long
as that
you know channel is going to still be
working for jk and then i'll have this
i'll come fly out
for big machines where are you going to
sleep
i mean i could stay at tiff's house or
whatever what i'm so excited about
is the big the big mood trips where we
get to all go to texas and like
yeah and then we're going to go to vegas
vegas we're going to be
[ __ ] going casinos yeah hella
bellagio
yeah i love all that um just having
money going into assets going into
investments it's like
compounding is the feeling that i got
when i started thinking in that
direction was like almost a sense of
relief
yeah because it's like when you start
getting more expensive things then you
start becoming addicted to them and it's
almost like you can't ever go backwards
otherwise it's like
emotionally difficult it feels like
you're failing yeah it feels like a
failure
that was me for a bit you know you guys
remember how i went through that
designer phase yeah
i kind of got bored of it and i'm just
like all right whatever that was a waste
of money and yeah
man i am stingy now yeah really it is
better to like not be
not it's almost like the nicer things
you have like you it feels good honestly
it feels great to be in the apartment
i'm in it feels great to have driven
that car
but then they start to weigh you down
like them like it's a weird thing that
and i guess rich people probably
understand this because a lot of rich
people you see like mark zuckerberg or
whatever he just wears this
ugly ass sweater like self-made
millionaires and billionaires
aren't they don't care about having
flashy yeah i mean obviously they have
mansions and [ __ ] but still it's just
like they know where to put their money
and like
where things matter i think that's so
much more fun like the game of finances
and like watching your money grow and
make money is like so much more exciting
to me than
having a fancy bag i don't know i don't
really get the
the purse culture um yeah i mean i mean
i do get like having nice things i i
like uh
i really like home decor like having
really nice
like cb2 stuff but um i can wait like
delayed gratification is the whole game
when it comes to that
and i didn't want that like i wanted
some i i felt like this year
or 2020 last year i needed some some
more instant gratification because yeah
i was in that that relationship for so
long and then i'm now all of a sudden
i'm alone
i'm in la like i just i needed some kind
of pick-me-up and it did it worked and
it gave me more self-confidence
yeah but now i'm like i don't need that
i think that now it's just like
knowing like when you walk by a bmw
you're like i could drive that if i
wanted to i chose her
i had that you know i had that baby and
i turned her in it's like it's still
empowering to know that you could and
you're not
when i could and if you ever want to
talk about it to somebody
if you ever have like if you even miss
it you're sad if you're crying about
training in your brain
you know or you do have a spending
addiction that's the thing yeah that's
very
true yeah can you talk to gina you can
talk to talkspace
talkspace is a a therapy app
where you can talk to real licensed
therapists
anytime you want talkspace is the number
one online therapy
platform that has thousands of licensed
therapists trained in over 40
specialties including anxiety
depression relationship issues substance
abuse and more
your therapist can help you set and
achieve your goals it's also very
affordable
talk space is a fraction of the cost of
in-person therapy
instead of waiting for an appointment
you can send unlimited messages to your
therapist 24 7
and they'll engage with you daily five
days a week
talkspace has thousands of licensed
therapists with years of experience
and is secure and private using the
latest end-to-end
bank grade encryption technology to
store client information
i actually use talkspace and i love it
because
um with regular therapy you go once a
week and you have to remember everything
that happened
everything that you felt but with toxins
it's very much more expensive yeah a
month of talk space
is about the price of one therapy
session uh
in-person therapy session but i liked it
because i can message my therapist
whenever
no matter what time it is you know and
then they check their messages and they
can respond
with um text messages or
video chatting or voice message if you
really like
need someone to actually speak to you as
a listener of this podcast you'll get a
hundred dollars off your first month
with talkspace
to match with a licensed therapist today
go to talkspace.com
and make sure you use the code mood to
get a hundred dollars off your first
month and show your support for the show
that's mood at talkspace.com for a
hundred dollars off
your first month and that is a lot of
dollars it really is
and lastly we would like to give a shout
out to ritual rituals
it really is really good i saw the panic
in her eyes like there is no subway
yeah it's anyways uh ritual vitamins
i've been taking these since like 2017
because i thought they were so
cute it smells like peppermint it does
they're it's the cutest vitamin on the
market and then you know what's more
important than
cute yeah yeah
we love aesthetics we deserve to know
what we're putting in our bodies and why
especially when it comes to something
you're taking every day
ritual is a multivitamin reimagined
with key nutrients and forms your body
can actually use to help fill in the
gaps in your diet with no shady extras
that's the biggest
problem with vitamins is a lot of
fillers yeah so ritual doesn't use all
those yeah
neon yellow that's the fun part
um rituals delayed release capsule is
designed to deliver high quality
nutrients including vitamin d3 which a
lot of women are short on vitamin d3
yes three of them have the same three
holes
now available for women men teens ritual
multivitamins are specifically developed
to help support
different life stages your multivitamins
are delivered to your door every month
with free shipping always you can start
snooze or cancel your subscription
anytime and if you don't love ritual
when
within your first month they'll refund
your first order so there's really
like no risk to try get key nutrients
without the bs
ritual is offering our listeners 10 off
during the first three months
visit ritual.com big mood to start your
ritual today
ritual.com slash big mood
i'm excited to start trying them because
i ordered the prenatal ones and i
ordered some for isaac the tea
vitamins yeah the prenatals i've been on
those and they're really good
but jess um speaking of assets and stuff
that's actually
kind of what's holding us up from moving
to vegas now is that
so last year in september we were super
amped and i was getting super excited we
were making a plan
uh we got pre-approved on a loan so that
we could start looking and
we've been house hunting in vegas but at
the beginning of this year we got our
house refinanced
it finally went through it took like two
or three months to go through and the
mortgage rates are
so good right now that now we went from
paying
thirty five hundred dollars a month on
our mortgage to paying nineteen hundred
dollars oh my god
in l.a three bedroom three bathroom
like with an outdoor space like you
can't find this deal in l.a not even as
a rental
so it's like uh but then also we want to
leave this deal
yeah but also it's like you could sell
that and get that cash back or whatever
but then like
trying to buy something else very hard
right now because it's very tempting to
sell it and go find a bigger house in
las vegas and that's that was our plan
but then yeah just like you're saying
when we were looking out there houses
were on the market for four days
sometimes less the places that we were
looking at already had
multiple offers on them and we weren't
even like sure if that was it for us so
i don't want to make a decision out of
like fomo exactly emotional financial
decisions usually come back to bite you
in the ass
yeah right and we love our house like we
really like it there so
yeah now it's making us more on the
fence um
even though i dream about being in vegas
all the time
uh i just wish i had like a swimming
pool how much is it to rent
out there it's about the same as here um
where it'd be like about two thousand
dollars a month
because i was thinking maybe we could
rent our place out i'll tell you in l.a
okay there you go yeah 2 000 a month
it's actually super cute it has a
laundry room the cats the weights
okay eight cats
yeah they've all them love them
yeah and actually because the rooms are
so spread out like you don't even feel
like you have that many cats unless
they're all in one room
but it's like it's like one cap per 400
square feet yeah
you always got a cat in there so then
where are you guys at now at this point
so we just bought an inflatable jacuzzi
because
i just feel like honestly nikki that was
one of her white trash summer
yeah i feel like that was a very poor
financial decision on you guys no i did
a lot of research
i don't know i saw it i saw the model i
just feel like we could have gotten a
better price for that
you know why i was like why were these
all like 300
last month but now they're like 800
dollars [ __ ]
twitch streamers man oh yeah i guess
there's some
trend now where you do hot tub streaming
yeah and it's a trend to have an
inflatable hot tub and stream from it
so it went from like 300 like whatever
we'll have a like a stupid
time and a 300 hot tub to like now it's
a thousand dollar investment if you like
it for a thousand dollars no i found a
deal a deal for 500. but that was after
searching
and price pricing things out for a while
and doing tons of research on
inflatable hobby i could tell you
everything about inflatable hot tubs i
also did a ton of research on like how
to maintenance them because a lot of
people just think it's like oh you buy
an inflatable hot tub and then it's like
no water in it
you actually need like all the chemicals
and how to treat it and stuff so
i have a whole treatment system and the
cool thing about the inflatable because
i was like maybe we should get a real
hot tub but
it's a 600 pound thing to do and i don't
think you can like i think you
need to crane it into our patio you did
that so i was like that's too much work
um so the inflatable you can like you
could take it down any time you know
when summer's over or you don't want it
anymore
or you're gonna show your house to
potential buyers i think you should
leave it up when you show your house
yeah
and it's so cute i'm getting so many
ideas because i have these like string
lights back there
and like it'll be cute it'll be trashy
cute so i want to put like
a budweiser neon side oh my god let me
just have like a you know patio yeah
i'll get you a nascar bikini
there you go perfect this is what
happens when you have adult money it's
so much fun yes
it's so much okay we also got a robot
bartender we're just having the time of
our life we're like
awesome la's been shut down for a
[ __ ] year now like how do we make
our house fun so we have a robot
bartender that makes all our drinks
he's really hot by the way he's very
called a robot no i love this machine
it's called drink works by cure but they
won't stop
for alcohol exactly but it actually
carbonates it makes its own soda
like it's it makes a perfect drink yeah
and the drinks are
pretty pretty potent like i get buzzed
off of one drink and
two i'm i'm done yeah uh so yeah we have
a robot bartender we're gonna take our
drinks to the
to the inflatable hot tub have you seen
it
yeah do you have it yet the hot tub yeah
yeah but i haven't set it up yet
um i have light us over i will i have my
rugs and then i'm getting new plants for
out there
and i'm going to have like i'm going to
make it like a cute little we'll have my
birthday party in your backyard there
you go
my pre birthday because i'll probably be
gone by my birthday
you better be coming back for retrograde
also your fence is very low so i can
sneak over anytime
there you go bubbles at four in the
morning
yeah gina's here again she has high
heels
it'll be low for her like that shit's
like seven feet tall
that's another thing is that it's a
corner lot so it's like private and and
quiet
like i don't know i i like a lot of our
a lot of the things in our house
and then we have another room for
exercise equipment so there's a
treadmill and like home gym stuff
you have everything you need everything
it's off of the kitchen
oh yeah before before steve's thieves
yeah yeah but that room always throws me
off that
i know it keeps going forever like
strange it's very deceiving yeah
our house looks like it's just gonna be
you know house reminds me you know like
when you play tetris and you get the one
that's like
going this way and three going that way
like yeah
put one that's exactly how it is yeah i
think you accidentally put one of the
wrong spots now that's the extended room
that's cool
i wanted to put a fake bookshelf in
between the kitchen and the exercise
room so it looks like it would be so
cool
there's no rooms back there and then
it's like secret it should be a
shelf where you put like your sugar and
all your your your uh yeah the pantries
yeah
stuff yeah and then there's two more
rooms behind it yeah
yeah a bathroom and a laundry room and a
bathroom
you could have secret slumber parties
back there it's a great dungeon
if you actually like blocked off that
wall and had a secret entrance
there's a lot you can do tina's like i
know look at her eyes rent that room can
i please
your
if you put like real doors instead of
the french doors you could probably like
rent that whole back area out because it
has its own laundry
washer dryer bathroom like it has its
own
like living room like everything so we
technically
could be like rent out that little side
i wonder because you know how like the
way your house is like you have to like
to get to your front door you know how
there's like that huge wall there i
wonder if you could put a door there
so you could be like oh there's another
the neighbor has his front door
in that area too though yeah there's
like a blank wall
that you pass yeah go to yours i don't
think
uh the hoa would let her blast it yeah
you can't do any of that
that's true better to ask for
forgiveness than permission
i got a fire pit last year and didn't
ask and i got too many complaints
because the smoke was going
oh really there was a lot of stuff it
was a lot of smoke i was not happy with
that fire pit
i was out there like it was pretty bad
would you do it
i put it on the street back to the
streets
what about you nothing
i literally okay yeah
you got a bunch of plants outside that's
the one thing i was gonna talk about and
that's the only thing that i've really
been i've been doing with my time is
yeah
i put now i'm a plant mom but i've been
a bad plant mom so the one week that we
went to hawaii
i thought it was like okay one week i
watered you guys i put globes in you
guys
you're gonna be good that should have
been okay yeah i got all kinds of plants
um but yeah like you know those water
globes that they could like water
themselves
so still died well some of you over
watered
maybe no they were thirsty as [ __ ] when
i got back they were so
thirsty and so
it was like spongebob when he's visiting
sandy it was literally like that and so
i lost
two okay so i have six brussels sprout
plants and two of them completely died
i didn't know you could just grow
straight up grow brussels sprouts on
your backyard well i'm attempting it
it's i really
can't i mean maybe not no actually those
brussels sprouts they're by my garage
because that's where the sun hits it so
it's like on the outside of my backyard
it's not even in my backyard
um and then so the other plants like i i
one little primrose one it completely
died
and i'm like really sad because they
were thriving they were
doing so good i hate that feeling yeah
and then the other one
so that one i think it's completely dead
too i had to trim it all down but like
in the very roots it looks like it's
like
trying to come back alive so i have high
hopes for that one and then the third
one because i had three of those
and the third one that one was like all
droopy and dying but then i put water in
it and then like it got erect
like that same day i even took a photo
and i was so happy i was like look casey
i got it it came back up
so i was like oh my god so yeah those
three i was like the most sad about
because
they were the ones that were like
thriving the hardest yeah and then this
other
plant that i had a heliotrope that one
was a like the buds were about to come
out and start flowering
i was so excited for that one and that
one totally [ __ ] died on me and i was
like oh
sorry i think you just bought plants
that are a little too finicky because i
was gone for 17
over 17 days and i watered mine and put
globes in them and they all stayed alive
wow so i think you just got the week
well also
i i also did not realize that one of the
plants that i had
it had like an af
infestation time for some ladybugs and
then yeah i need to buy some
i still have them i could just straight
up buy a ladybug yeah those like stay on
the plant
jar yeah because that's what they eat
they like eating the aphids
but i haven't gotten the ladybugs and i
just recently ordered neem oil which a
lot of people would tell me to get and i
should have gotten it
when i whatever i didn't get it until
just recently
and so a lot of these spider mites too
yeah and
i have some of those too like there's
like this infestation of all my plants
with all these bugs and i'm like i'm
sorry i failed you guys i was gone one
week
when you bought it at the store they
were already infested you could how did
they get infected
well they also spread from plant to
plants so if one of your houseplants has
it at home like they can
spread it yeah it was actually the
brussels sprouts that had them
initially yeah and i didn't know that
they weren't going to be hoes too they
needed google docs
but spider mites oh my god are the bane
of my [ __ ] plant life existence i
use neem oil sometimes i feel like i won
and then they come back
like they planted little freaking eggs
or something
what if you just get rid of all your
plants and start over not all of them i
got rid of the ones that had the spider
mites and they were in a separate
section of the house
so hopefully they don't come back but
yeah it is it pisses me off i hate
the second i see those little webs i'm
like oh it's gonna be
warm on fire
yeah really oh and also i've had um have
you gotten those gnats yet
those fungus tiny ones yeah because i
have three plants inside the house
and i have one of those like little tiny
nats like flying around but
i always think it's like my eyelashes
playing tricks on me because sometimes i
have like mascara bits inside my
eyeballs
and then they're trying to eat your eyes
no so that's
big eye problems okay gabby so like i
get a lot of [ __ ] in my eyes all the
time and so sometimes like
i'll be i'll be like blinking and i'll
assume you have gnats like always
what's the charlie brown character yeah
i know
no it's a or sometimes like minus not
linus it's uh his pig pen
oh yeah yeah sometimes i remember that
tiff just always has a nap
i always have like [ __ ] or like my
eyelashes like it has like a chunk of
mascara on it and like i'll think
something's like right here and i'll
look i'm like oh [ __ ] it's gone it's my
[ __ ] mascara
so i'm constantly like i never know
what's real oh my god but no for sure
i've seen this [ __ ] that because my
cats are always like doing that
yeah yeah yeah i love that and they're
like trying to hunt
so i'm like okay i know that's not just
my my eyeballs well
you'll know when you have an infestation
though because they're freaking
everywhere crawling freaking everywhere
even though they have wings they just
[ __ ] those plants
yeah i think i got lucky because my
plants have no bugs in them or it's good
yeah check your plants at the stores for
sure four stories up so i don't know if
like they just don't get up
like high up in the sky or um i just
bought plants that weren't infected yeah
they should like for the most part
plants shouldn't have diseases or
problems but
you know like it's not uncommon for
for a plant to catch something oh man
the first time i see [ __ ] gnats and
spiders and [ __ ]
these plants are gone especially if you
get them from big box stores like home
depot
i did yeah i got four real plants from
home to you because my house is full of
fake plants yeah
and i was like i want to be kind of a
plant mom so i bought four real ones and
they're thriving
good no nuts and bugs so i'm like i
think i got lucky i always get bit by
mosquitos cause they're not dying
well it's another thing too that's
really difficult for me to figure out is
because my
my backyard like the patio area where i
have all my plants
it's all on like this counter space and
that
part of my my property only gets sun
about like an hour
and a half ish like tops but like it
moves so it's not even like in one spot
so it doesn't get a lot of sun so for
that reason i bought a lot of like house
plants
to put out there but then i think the
the amount of sun that
they do get is too much for them so then
i'm like trying to shaded outdoor plants
that you can buy
or you can but those are the ones that
are the ones i'm talking about that i
think
they're getting a little too much sun so
i actually have some like i have my
croton my lily and my
antrium atrium whatever um that one i
have
under my umbrella so i actually opened
my umbrella to
shade those three plants because those
are the ones that are getting like sun
spots like
burning they don't like direct sunlight
so i'm like [ __ ] man plant life is hard
yeah
especially if you have potted plants
outside because
it's easier if they're planted directly
into the ground with their outdoor
plants but when they're potted
they like have different rules it's
ridiculous
but the more you go through the more you
learn you had a problem
i feel myself like kind of get um
like discouraged yeah instead of being
motivated to learn more i'm kind of
getting discouraged because i'm like
i don't [ __ ] know this is too hard
like with cooking i'm like
listen i'll [ __ ] cook if i have to
but if i don't have to then [ __ ] it i
don't know it's too hard
so i'm just like i'm like i don't know i
think i think the plant life might not
be
you've got too many plants maybe just
have like a lot of yeah i definitely
have
a lot of because that happens when
you're first getting started you're like
oh my god i want this one too and this
one this one yeah and then
my my idea was to like fill up that
whole space and there's still like
chunks of that
cardboard spot yeah wait what i say
cardboard no there's still chunks of
that
countertop that is bald and i'm like i
need to fill them with more
pictures of the ones i bought because
i've had zero issues with them
and they're outside in the shaded area
okay so venus
and they'll give you more than one a
venus venus
of course you would kill it uh no
when i was like 19 years old my ex took
it he loved him it was fun to have i
almost bought that one too
do they actually eat flies yeah and then
i put little ants in there too oh my
gosh you're
feeling mean yeah i like it very weird
that we own plants like that yeah well i
forgot to tell you
there's a very exciting thing that i'm
doing soon what do you do
but i can't tell you guys yet because
it's a secret and i don't know if it's
going to be out here why'd you even
bring it up because i wanted to share my
excitement with you guys well they know
right
they know but but you can't say i can't
say wait i know
yeah we know yeah you guys know but we
can't say yeah yeah yeah we can't say it
yes because we got a rap but maybe if
you tune in next week
we'll be here don't make promises i said
maybe
maybe aliens will land next week we
don't know maybe tiff's plants will
survive
maybe no who knows i don't know it's
like a rocky and bulbous oh my god wait
actually before we go can somebody make
just fall in love
with them really hard so that she
doesn't move and she's like i can't
leave because i want to be with this guy
please please just somebody
yeah you guys have an assignment i'm in
love with just watching my money grow
[ __ ]
okay rich guy that gives her money no i
don't have money no
money fine go back to your google docs
see you next week everybody bye thanks
for watching make sure you guys give us
a thumbs up
and five stars and everything i love you
bye so we need it we're needy billy
raiser